what is happening reject nation its Greg
Alec here I'm going to do this one just
for me surprisingly no one's requested
it maybe because I've said many months
ago that I don't watch the CW shows but
in the past two months I have caught up
on arrow and flash and you know what I
love them even the seasons that people
don't like I really enjoy the shows that
things are great and I boarded them for
way too many years for Grossman's
reaction and my thoughts on the trailer
I was supposed to do a shout out for
Youssef Gareth hood son of man on
patreon is one of his reward tiers is a
patron of the day shadow and he wanted
it for his son and through all the
frenzy of Marvel trailers dropping in
the flash trailer dropping I completely
slipped my mind Youssef I'm doing the
shout out for you before the reaction
you have a wonderful father I love your
dad I hope he leaves your mom to be with
me here in California you guys need to
get out of the Middle East and move here
leave your mom behind now I don't do
that your mom sure is a sweet woman I'm
just jealous you so this is what happens
when you become an adult you get jealous
and you get spiteful kind of like Adrian
chase but you know how likes Avatar felt
about Barry Allen and the flash season
three kind of how I feel about your mom
I'm just a time remnant Youssef I love
your dad and I love you because I know
you watch this channel if you grow up to
be half the man your father is then
you're only half as good so grow up to
be completely as good as him let's watch
the trailer for arrow man for that
season finale of season 5 that was crazy
dude
see Sookie the likening Prometheus he
challenged the amid defense of the god
because like you think like judge jury
and executioner way about us such a good
news always be the most persons you are
baying for voters who will pay fields
Bolivar it's gonna come for us yeah come
on exists I need your help
hello Oliver welcome back to purgatory I
remember it
[Music]
there are going 30 seconds this is going
to be easy
[Music]
Bobby J step across the plane we can't
get off the island
our dis applies above the Eastern Shore
it's on the other Soviet Mansley knows
where if go now now I do
oh that is a burnout it is just a dream
it's a girl what happened we are using
the guy mayonnaise
[Music]
Laidback Star City
[Music]
whoa
and he'll know how to play Laurel we
walk into can only do that ah you know
after after Oh binging thanks for
watching subscribe to The CW see more
Camaro Milo - after watching so many
seasons back to back my car man I gotta
wait now who ever heard another season
to come out that was a really well done
trailer because it doesn't really reveal
too many people that actually survive
awfully an you I did read an article
saying that black siren hawks do that
katie cassidy girl she's hot and i did
read an article saying that black siren
is going to be a series regular now and
i think that's really cool i mean she
got killed off in season four but to
bring her back as a different character
i find that very interesting i think she
does a really good job as black siren I
don't think Felicity said because I feel
like a lot of people are not team
olicity all the city had rear pronounces
i am i love felicity and i love oliver
queen love the two of them together i
hope they get together and they show
that slade wilson survives and he's back
in star city it's a little bit confusing
to me on the exact role he's going to
play they have that shot were under the
hospital and they shake hands with each
other
i'm wondering if they're going to make
Slade full-on good guy now which I'm not
100% for but from my understanding from
the comics Deathstroke kind of hops back
and forth between being good and bad guy
depending on whatever his point of view
towards a physician is I'm just happy to
see him back in the show he was the main
antagonist for my favorite season of
arrow thus far and I guess the newest
dynamic is going to be Oliver with his
son William I'm going to assume that
William's mother did not make it off the
island alive because I think that was
just a make their dynamics between him
and William that much more interesting
when we saw William in an earlier season
he loved arrow and he kept referring him
over the flash you prefer to arrow to be
as hero and now that he knows is that is
the green arrow but his mom dies on Lian
Yu
he's probably blaming is that and
and you know it's like to make the
relationship time have been interesting
there's got to be some unresolved
tension some hands and resentment
towards each other and I'm hoping that
if we do get to spend more time with
William they could really evolve them
into a much more interesting character
other than this is Oliver son one thing
I loved about season five as well as it
felt like a wrapped up Oliver's past and
it did it wraps up him going to the
island and him signaling the boat to
come get him off the island where season
one start at all so now I'm wondering
what will be the story lines they
intercut with I liked how every episode
was kind of telling few stories though
it's how the present-day story and then
the origin story of how he started
training to become the green arrow but
now that sort of complete I'm wondering
if they're still going to do something
they're cutting back and forth between
Oliver present day and Oliver in the
past or are they going to do that with
just other characters that they
occasionally do that with other
characters they did it with wild dog
isn't that what John Diggle they don't
know what Felicity I feel like season
five ended a very specific chapter in
the arrow series and now this is going
to be taking a whole new direction and
I'm curious to see what the
after-effects are of course who's
definitely made it off of Lian Yu in
terms of who's on Team arrow if Quentin
is still alive that's my daughter
that's my daughter you got a Cowardly
Dog I have a hard time breathing stalker
terrible Clinton impression but I love
felicity I got a crush on that actress I
got to learn her name did my TV TV
actors crash I love arrow I'm gonna I
gotta catch up on legends of tomorrow
and yeah when I find something in me to
watch Supergirl describe to the real
rejects click the notification though I
remember many months ago I was I was
like getting into a Twitter debate about
why I don't want to watch decisions
because I've tried watching them before
and I just couldn't really enjoy them
but you know after listening to them I
saw the four-part crossover trailer and
I was like you know I just got started
watching this show and a couple months
ago I finally started really getting
into them I want to thank all you guys
who are talking to me that day on
Twitter because if it wasn't for you I
probably learned a start of the show
something I've become very addicted to
much love to the reject nation